[Music]
critic critic okay hmm
nostalgia critic who nostalgia critic is
this your car out here that's the fact
could you open the door please
yeah yeah just the fact seriously critic
get a hold of yourself think about it
it's just Adam Sandler
let's take a look at the first film in
history to win a Razzie award in every
category Jack and Jill this is a film so
infamously despised that even the
trailer got people deeming it the worst
movie ever helped the mere idea got
people saying it's the worst movie ever
Adam Sandler has a twin sister who what
a shock is loud love's farts and has no
distinct character outside of an unfunny
voice you've got an hour and a half of
that baby the comic comparison is that
it looks like one of the fake movies
made up in Adam Sandler's dramatic
comedy funny people mocking the cheap
humor of his films but this isn't satire
this is real life where dreams go to die
it appears on a ton of horse films ever
lists it's said to be Sandler's worse
even by Adam Sandler movie standards and
for some reason whoo we gotta take a
look at it let's not waste any time as
we have a whole film that's gonna do
that this is Jack and Jill it opens with
a collection of twins talking about what
it's like to be twins on the set of a
milk commercial a married couple you
can't divorce her
I just knew going in I'd be comparing
this to when Harry Met Sally who just
make these sounds it's like despite it
being kind of grating why do I feel like
this annoyance is still gonna be the
best part of the movie cut to a baby
farting so far my assumptions correct
give them credit that even from the
start they don't try to make the sister
look like a girl they just dress up a
pair of twin boys granted Sandy's
amazing ability to create fleshed out
characters through strangling cat noises
doesn't go unappreciated
should get to a voice slightly less
annoying
hold it got Jack are you watching this
no I did say just slightly
it looks like Sandler's on the set of a
commercial or an unused Dana Carvey show
sketch as he plays Jack an ad executive
who oh my god an ad executive really
really okay look at I know that doesn't
sound like a big deal but here's the
thing Sandler's films are infamously
known for their product placements
they're always trying to sneak in
advertisements well not sneak as much as
violently bludgeon you with man is you
who is good
by the Reese's Peanut Butter Cup and
some Gatorade
so now they literally just make him an
ad executive just cut through the
he's gonna be surrounded by ads and
after the opening credits how many
points do we have we may lose Dunkin
Donuts
well Never Say Never it could only get
worse by making it the focus of the
story plan they want Al Pacino to do a
commercial they got this new coffee
drink the dunkaccino dunkaccino Al
Pacino they sound alike
oh yeah that's his mission throughout
the entire film trying to get Al Pacino
to advertise the dunkaccino remember you
didn't think we'd give Brad Pitt to do
that RadioShack commercial I could go
for a diet coke right now oh my god is
working on me and I didn't even know
it's we're up to four product placements
in the first four minutes that's a
product placement per minute for the
love of insert your ads you're just
palace all right where were you come
back to the product placements go back
to the brownie placements so believe it
or not that Sandler as the twin sister
who flew in for Thanksgiving an American
airline are you sure Adam Sandler
himself isn't a product buy at this
point now Jill is different from
Sandler's wide range of characters who
are loud high-pitched and evah Lisp
because this one also has boobs oh wait
he's done that before there is no
difference between this and his other
characters oh and she also has a talking
bird which I guess could be funny but it
literally just says one cat phrase even
if you were gonna do that could it be
something funny at least it says over
and over like learn how to say stop boy
you dumb bird I'm gonna lose my job if I
don't teach you this product placement
dumb bird not that the other two loud
parakeets they are never funny are much
better though those are both Adam
Sandler sorry did they blend so we cut
to San Luis Thanksgiving which comprises
of a homeless man a girl in a pilgrim
costume
a boy who tapes things to himself and
Katie Holmes why is Katie Holmes the
strangest thing in that lineup and it
looks like they all sit down to eat
dinner
[Music]
yeah I love the old one you ever wonder
what would happen if Linda from Bob's
Burgers took on the identity of any of
the Monty Python actors and drag you
haven't you shouldn't but you are now
thanks movie I'm allowed out here once a
year though I tend to miss things Sophie
just got her green belt in karate I
didn't even know she did karate whether
I'm in the twilight zone right now
trust me Christ you're not alone I'm
like Jimmy fill it at the end of that
movie that one would have been positive
okay we all know what this jokes gonna
be they're gonna say a wonderful life
and she's not gonna believe him next
It's a Wonderful Life no no with Jimmy
Stewart that one way he meets the angel
It's a Wonderful Life why do you keep
saying that oh my god we're not a little
Nicki almost yep but sweet Jesus were
tight-roping there Oh
pagogo I can't stand you be here it's
like a white Madea Thanksgiving except
there's two Madea
stop running that down Tyler Perry and
now a great impression of everyone who
saw this film this is really awkward I'm
gonna go a little too calm and collected
though she'll gets upset and runs
outside leading to oh joy more screaming
15 minutes in and already I'm praying
for nuclear annihilation I knew you
didn't love me God it looks like the
family hasn't turned her name Felipe
it's about as funny as everything else
plenty me groceries she'll stop I do a
great impression of a tree let you
compare son Jill says she wants to stay
longer at the house and Jack
begrudgingly agrees yeah this was
supposed to be an American Girl doll
plug but they remember they like having
customers as if things weren't
incestuously creepy enough that is
actually what you wake up to in hell or
at least it probably should be stop
writing that down Satan no they go on
The Price is Right because somebody is
blackmail photos of somebody and Jill
gets to spin the wheel good luck to you
I don't even know how that was supposed
to knock her out didn't look like
there's anything in the wheel tune that
karate you know it is quiet for a few
seconds I'll count my blessings they
partake in the trailer shot with six
reminders to drink coke trust me I'll be
seeing lots of coke after this film is
over as chill cell phone goes off please
stop talking well now you're just
confusing the audience no Adam Sandler
viewer would interpret this as rude to
make Jill feel better after apparently
jack was acting out of line according to
his idiot idiots maybe she's lonely and
she needs someone to get her through the
holidays he sets her up for online
dating and lies on her profile to get a
lot more dates what you gonna wear I'll
give the film a smart point on that one
the date is of course cameo number 50
who is shocked to find who he's going
out with I live in the Bronx you know
Sandler I'm aware we both got or kind of
anti humor thing going on but how are
you anti humor oh he ends up hanging on
the light in the bathroom for dozens of
minutes to escape because just going out
the door made too much sense as
juveniles how bad her date went
[Music]
now give the film this it's great insect
repellent why are you an idiot I mean we
know why we just really want to hear you
say it Jack feels bad about setting her
up so he takes her to a basketball game
that it just so happens Al Pacino is
that what's going on with a beard I
don't want people to know I'm in an Adam
Sandler movie
honestly if we're going by current movie
roles Depp should be the one in the
beard Jack tries talking to Al Pacino
and of course Pacino falls in love with
Jill
compliments to mr. Pacino what it's a
dead horse's head and hey if you think
Depp's cameo doesn't age well check this
one out just just chair it's fine I miss
the old Jarrett he was around he'd be
with me and not with the two hookers
which by the way aren't they look older
than what you're used to
check out this strangeness when it's
revealed that somebody there is an
atheist you really make me mad you hear
those bodies falling
that's just another piece of comedy
dying but Al Pacino finds out about
their get together and follows Jill
don't be startled it's only me you alone
not so scary
you and a jack-and-jill movie terrifying
[Applause]
[Music]
so Pacino takes Jill to his home and I
know this is gonna sound insane but Al
Pacino's love for her is awkwardly
hilarious
he's like weirdly into it
it's time for my salvation I found one
woman with a long rough you and John who
lead me back to sanity even when he has
her do something as stupid as play ball
in his office
leading to wall something breaking he's
still pretty damn funny through it I'm
sure are you thinking but oddly enough I
don't and movies like this is why but
hell with that we have Felipe's birthday
party to go to
can't overlook that my kids awesome is
there Chinese festival going on too
maybe we can break out the breakfast at
tiffany's make up for Rob Schneider
never show that woman again for the love
of God you're gonna show her a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
you know why don't you just show the
robbers a joy constantly stealing all
happiness from you when your self-love
returns they will purge it with this
film no no she got knocked out better
feed her jalapenos because you know
Mexicans you know that joke was so funny
and such good commentary let's do it
twice peppers are Mexicans life juice
it's light because the people have wrote
this joke are going to hell
meanwhile Pacino breaks into Jack's
house to find Jill and comes across her
sweat stains on the bed
Al Pacino said yes to this but again
this is old al pacino young out but
she'll probably done this to the movie
so Pacino tells him they have Jack gets
in Jill he'll do the Dunkin Donuts
commercial I mean come on how can you
not go for a person like this I think
this is how every Sandler script is
written line fart line fart line it's an
elegant dance of
Pacino takes a call literally in the
middle of a play again surprisingly kind
of funny if Jack can't seem to convince
Jill to go on a date with Pacino so of
course he dresses up like her on a
cruise to meet up with him the bathroom
attendant even straighten some out so to
speak oh I guess but she no flies a
helicopter overhead and picks him up and
keeping with Pacino being the only semi
entertaining thing in this we get our
first legit laugh out loud joke I used
to raise business really yeah no I'm
sorry that was Brando oh that was a
really good job too with such a good
record going don't worry though it gets
more awkward you know
so empty why does this make me feel so
bad
sure enough Jill calls and finds out but
he's pretending to be her breaking her
poor little heart because I am so ready
to have an emotional scene with this
character
I think I'd cry more with this guy but
okay here's a classic setup we know
exactly where this is gonna go but they
can't possibly screw it up right know
what's coming it's done wrong we know
exactly what he's gonna do and that
she's obviously gonna hit him so you
gotta deliver it a little differently
like here here's a different edit of the
same scene that works better because it
allows us to put the pieces together it
doesn't have to be spelled out it
respects our intelligence and I know
it's ironically stupid thinking Jack and
Jill will respect our intelligence but
I'm sorry I have some hope for something
jack realizes he betrayed his sister
though and he gets back on the cruise
ship yeah good
Jill was right you are a weird home and
I'm married to Tom Cruise
speaking of weirdos David Spade is in
this movie too
let's see if they use him to his full
potential yeah sounds about right
but jack appears to tell Jill just how
much she means to him and their secret
language
Margot dodo pokey oh go go to ID not
neat punky you know it's only a matter
of time before Sandler films got so bad
at being sentimental that even his
gibberish is trying to sound emotional
but lady spade insults Jack's wife so
Jill insults lady Spade and lady spade
tackles Jack's wife and Al Pacino comes
in as Don Quixote
Bato oh this feels justified oh my god
is that Colonel Sanders no that was
earlier your purity befits a knight more
worthy tonight
go to him hey weights fine
you know Pacino I was actually enjoying
you're weird but then you went and made
it weird it's a foul monster oh let's
just go you don't care how the seen it
they go to see Philippe who apparently
shoveled all the fake snow off his house
seriously it looks like shaving cream
popcorn
em Philippe confesses his love to Jill
because now was the thing apparently a
happy ending or so they tell us but hey
I don't think we plug Dunkin Donuts
enough
what's my name Danka Gina it's a whole
new game dark Cochino say hello to my
chocolate blip so this is a mental
breakdown first Gary is a thug the Chino
is supposed to give his thoughts on the
commercial at the end but you know what
just show what he's really talking about
burn this I'm sorry all copies destroy
them I couldn't agree more
Jack and Jill is Jack Shannon Jill Jett
the only thing it has going for it is
oddly enough Al Pacino's weird ass
performance I hate to say it but his
dedication steals the show and give me
funny once in a while aside from that
though it's pretty much as annoying
grating and painfully obnoxious as you
would expect if he can't figure out this
is gonna be a stinking pile then maybe
you deserve the awful film you got
coming to you for me if it looks like a
dump and smells like a dump
it must be Jack and Jill I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember where do you
want us to put these release it after
you bury every copy of this movie ever
made but we can't do that
every copy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you